Our focus is instead to compute the histogram itself.
Look forward in this week's assignment.
You'll compute the histogram of pixel intensity values in an image.
Histograms are not a difficult problem if you think about them serially,
but they get more interesting and parallel.
So let's first take a look at the serial histogram algorithm. Here's our code here.
We're going to have 2 for loops where we loop over all the histogram bins.
So in the first phase, we initialize all the Bins to 0, the counts for each of the bins to zero.
This is so simple, we're not going to mention it again. Much more interesting is the second phase.
We're going to loop through all the data measurements.
For each data measurement, we first determine to which bin it belongs.
That's the compute bin call. And I'll show an example in a second.
Then we fetch the current value of that bin,
increment it, and store the new value back into the bin.
For instance, in the previous example, let's say the input to compute bin is 175 centimeters.
So we take a measurement. It's 175 centimeters.
Compute bin then decides which of these bins is associated with 175 centimeters.
In this case, compute bin would return this bin
because it stores all of the measurements between 165 and 180.
So, we take 175. It's then associated with this bin, and now we increment the value of this bin.
So now let's consider these 4 bins, and we're going to trace
a program with the 4 measurements 155, 150, 175, and 170 centimeters.
So the first loop here will initialize each of these bins to 0 items, and then we'll
walk through these 4 measurements using compute bin to decide which bin they're in
and incrementing the values in those bins.
So, first we'll consider 155.
Compute bin will tell us it's in this bin right here, so I'll increment its value to 1.
Then we look at 150. Compute bin will tell us its value is in this bin again,
and we'll increment its value to 2.
Next we'll consider 175, which is associated with this bin.
And now we've incremented its value.
And finally 170 will allow us to store 2.
So a couple of quick questions to make sure you understand the histogram.
Let's say we have n measurements and b bins.
As a function of n and b, what is the maximum number of
measurements we would possibly ever see per bin,
and what is the average number of measurement you would see per bin?